bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur Public
Sénat à 3 semaines à peine des élections
départementale et alors que l'Assemblée
nationale examine en ce moment la
réforme territoriale le Sénat
s'intéresse au budget des départements
hier un débat eu lieu dans l'hémicycle à
la demande des groupes UMP et centristes
à ce sujet beaucoup sénateurs se sont
inquiétés de la baisse des dotations de
l'État pour vous donner un chiffre un
seul ça fait environ 4 milliards d'euros
de moins pour les départements entre
2014 et 2017 une baisse donc des
recettes qui se conjugue avec une hausse
inexorable des dépenses quand on sait
que les département s'occupe des
solidarités sociales et territoriales
avec notamment le RSA ils sont donc pour
certains étranglés ajouter à cela un
contexte d'incertitude les départements
ne savent pas encore quelles seront
leurs compétences c'est l'objet de la la
loi nôre voilà vous avez tous les
ingrédients pour un débat vif et musclé
sur ce sujet dans l'hémicycle tout de
suite direction la
séance alors la parole est d'abord aux
orateurs des groupes et notamment au
président Jean-Léon
Dupont monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président mes chers collègues nous avons
aujourd'hui à débattre de la situation
financière des conseils départementaux
face à l'évolution de leur charge ce
débat a lieu alors qu'au moment où nous
parlons nous ne savons pas ce que
deviendront les départements dans la
nouvelle organisation
territoriale notamment dans la
répartition des compétences nous devrons
attendre que les débats entrent dans la
dernière le droite parlementaire et dans
ce flou général les élus concernés ont
bien du mal à se projeter dans un avenir
à moyen terme dans le rapport annuel les
magistrats de la Cour des comptes
affirment que la vive progression des
dépenses sociales et la moindre capacité
des départements à ajuster leurs
recettes pour couvrir l'ensemble de
leurs dépenses rendent plus difficile le
maintien d'un équilibre de moyen terme
le statut quo n'est pas possible loin de
l'idée souvent répandue ces derniers
mois par certains que les départements
seraient mal gérés simplement plus de 80
% des dépenses de fonctionnement sont
concentré sur des charges obligatoire
difficilement compressible en 2015 par
exemple le taux de rigidité des dépenses
pour le département du Calvados est de
82,6 %. le problème majeur que rencontre
aujourd'hui la plupart des départements
se concentre sur le financement des
allocations individuelles de solidarité
les conseils généraux versent le RSA à
près de 1,6 millions de bénéficiaires et
dépense pour cela 11,6 fois plus qu'en
2003 de même qu'il verse l'allocation
personnelle d'autonomie la pas à 1 2
million de personnes dépendantes quant
aux prestations versées aux handicapés
elles ont progressé de 120 % en 5 ans en
2015 ces droits àocations représentent
toujours dans le budget du département
du Calvados ce que je connais bien près
de 27 % des dépenses de fonctionnement
hors frais de gestion les départements
disparaîtraient que ce problème
resterait entier et serait même pire
tant la départementalisation de l'action
sociale s'est accompagnée contraire à ce
que l'on peut souvent entendre d'une
maîtrise de la gestion des dépenses
sociales mais la réalité est là depuis
2003 les dépenses sociales ont doublé et
cela aucune mesure de gestion si saine
soit-elle n'y peut rien impact de la
crise économique vieillissement de la
population mais aussi transfert de
compétences de l'État vers les
départements explique cette inflation or
les transferts financiers n'ont pas
suivi le problème est aujourd'hui
nationale car si plus personne n'ignore
les graves difficultés financières de
notre système de protection sociale les
départements peineent à se faire
entendre sur l'impossible équation
financière qu'ils doivent résoudre pour
gérer les allocations nationales de
solidarité le problème est d'autant plus
complexe qu'il s'accompagne d'une très
grande disparité de situation
territoriale ainsi les bénéficiaires de
la part représente 3,7 % de la
population du Nord alors qu'il
représente 12,8 % dans l'avyon
il existe également des fin des
disparités de financement si le
financement était entièrement local un
habitant deesson devrait payer seulement
78 € par an au titre de la dépendance là
où un creusois devrait en débourser
375 la part de la pas dans le budget de
laavyon de la Creuse et du gerse se
situe autour de 14 % alors que les
ivelines les sones et les hautes scèes y
consacrent moins de 5 % si rien n'est
fait pour combler ces inégalités on
pourrait rapidement aboutir pour
certains départements à une véritable
impasse budgétaire pour ne pas dire
cessation de paiement compte tenu des
perspectives économiques
actuelles autre exemple le RSA le taux
de couverture par l'état des dépenses
départementales lié au RSA était en 2004
de 92,2 % il n'a cessé de chuter pour
atteindre 71,3 % en 2013
et chacun sait que la situation s'est
encore dégradée entre 2014 et début 2015
pour rester dans le Calvados le reste à
charge sur le RSA est passé de 3
millions d'euros en 2005 à 33 millions
d'euros dans le budget
2015 ces transferts de responsabilité se
sont accompagnés de changement
d'affectation de personnel comme le
souligne la Cour des comptes dans son
dernier rapport sur les collectivités
territoriales les l'effet des transferts
de personnel en provenance de l'État en
lien avec la décentralisation des
compétences explique l'augmentation de
plus de 4000 80000 emploi il ne
s'agendique donc en rien des suites
d'une gestion irresponsable des élus
locaux ce qui devient insupportable à
entendre si ces transferts n'expliquent
pas à eux seuls l'augmentation de la
masse salariale c'est que les charges de
personnel ont aussi cru sous l'effet du
vieillesse technicité des mesures
nationales de revalorisation de l'indice
de rémunération des fonctionnaires de la
réforme des catégories de la garantie de
pouvoir d'achat autant dire de mesures
décidées au plan national l'État
continue de décider seul des dépenses
qui impactent les budgets des
collectivités territoriales ainsi en
2013 et 2015 les décisions unilatérales
de l'État pèse pour plus de 8 millions
d'euros dans le budget du département du
Calvados il en est pour preuve la
réforme des rythmes scolaires
l'augmentation du RSA l'accueil d'un
cota admiteteur étranger isolé dont la
charge départementale est en train
d'exploser la revalorisation de la TVA
le changement de régime de cotisation de
retraite des élus et cetera et cetera or
contrairement aux communes et comme les
régions les départements n'ont plus
d'autonomie fiscale si leur charges
augmentent les départements perçoivent
une fiscalité qui tend à stagner comme
la cont contribution à la valeur ajoutée
des entreprises voire à diminuer comme
les droits de mutation immobilière en
outre la réforme de la fiscalité locale
a fortement réduit la capacité des
départements à recourir au levier fiscal
alors que les conseils généraux sont les
principaux financeurs du monde rural et
péri urbain enfin la baisse des
dotations de l'État et l'augmentation de
certains prélèvements viennent clore un
cercle vicieux qui alimente un déficit
structurel chronique dès lors et pour
faire face à ces dépenses obligatoires
les conseils généraux doivent arbitrer
sur les autres postes budgétairees afin
de dégager des ressources
supplémentaires charge de personnel
entretien des routes par exemple les
investissements pâtissent alors d'une
diminution de la capacité
d'autofinancement de nos collectivités
le présent au détriment de l'avenir la
situation des départements est sans
rapport avec celle d'autres niveaux le
problème on l'a dit est structurel
les dépenses des départements RSA PCH
APA sont contrat cycliques elles
augmentent lorsque l'économie va mal
comme actuellement tandis que les
recettes sont en théorie procyclique
CVAE DMTO TFPB et en pratique pour la
plupart figé dans leur étude sur la
prospective financière des collectivités
locales à l'horizon 2020 Guy Gilbert
professeur à l'École normale supérieure
de Cachan et Alain Gangan directeur de
recherche honoraire au CNRS ont conclu
que je cite le modèle financier des
départements ne peut pas résister à la
baisse des dotations de l'État cette
étude rejoint l'analyse unanime de
l'ensemble des observateurs des
collectivités locales ainsi que le
signal d'alarme tiré par l'Assemblée des
départements de France au-delà de ces
constats alarmants quelle solution il
faudrait déjà dispenser les départements
de contribuer au redressement des compte
public ou tout le moins exclure de leur
assiette dans le poids des dépenses
publiques locales les dépenses qui
relèvent d'une compétence national comme
les allocations individuelles de
solidarité
ensuite choisir au-delà de la nécessité
d'un article 40 pour toutes dépenses
voté par le législateur il faudrait soit
rééquilibrer la fiscalité directe entre
le bloc local et le bloc
départemental soit abandonner le
principe des recette locale au profit
d'un pourcentage de recette nationale je
n'y étais pas jusqu'ici favorable mais
les risques catastrophiques les
conséquences catastrophiques de décision
de gouvernement successives m'amèneent à
y réfléchir parallèlement à cela et sur
le fond l'action sociale doit être
remodelée en redéfinissant par exemple
les conditions d'accès aux ais sur le
mode de ce qui avait été envisagé autour
du projet de loi sur le 5e risque
on ne peut indéfiniment continuer à
augmenter les dépenses au niveau
gouvernemental en accroissant les
mesures généreuses sans se préoccuper de
leur financement par les départements
aujourd'hui mes chers collègues nous
sommes rattrapés par la réalité à nous
de mettre en œuvre les mesures qui
s'imposent pour adapter le système
actuel de protection sociale et lui
permettre de perdurer à défaut nous
courons collectivement le risque de
porter la responsabilité de son
effondrement il est plus que temps d'
d'agir les paroles lénifiantes ne
suffisent
plus la parole est à d'utrre collègues
René Paul Savari pour le groupe
UMP
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues merci pour
vos encouragements dans cette épreuve
redoutable que de parler des finances
départementales c'est sûr que c'est un
exercice difficile qui n'a échappé à
personne puis maintenant que les
départements sont là hein puisqu'il va y
avoir des élections monsieur le ministre
après les tergiversations vous l'avez
dit c'est un échelon incontournable
alors autant que les départements vivent
et en ayant les moyens d'exercer leurs
compétences sinon ce serait tout à fait
inutile d'avoir voulu les supprimer pour
finalement les maintenir et faire qu'
est toujours un échon s'il n'a pas les
moyens effectivement nécessairire par
rapport aux difficultés d'ailleurs
rencontrées par nos concitoyens et qui
sont là aussi exigeants à juste titre
Contu des services qu'on a déjà su leur
amener à travers les les conseils les
conseils généraux alors je ne reviendrai
pas sur les propos de de de Jean-Léon
Dupont que je partage bien sûr
entièrement j'essaierai de faire
l'analyse d'utre qui
qui ont prévalu peut-être par pour les
notations que l'on voit fleurir au sein
des différents médias actuel et montrer
que derrière il y a peut-être un
changement de mentalité qui sera
instauré si on veut maintenir
effectivement la survie des départements
dès l'instant monsieur le ministre on en
a la volonté parce que si on veut
effectivement les tuer on peut s'y
prendre comme on s'y prend actuellement
continuer et on y arrivera de façon sont
tout à fait naturells très rapidement
bien sûr que les budgets des
départements sont complètement
déséquilibrés c'est la raison pour
laquelle on peut se demander s'il y a
des bons et des mauvais gestionnaires
alors on nous donne des notes alors moi
j'ai pris c'est effectivement le
classement qui m'arrangé le mieux entre
nous bien entendu celui de l'Association
des contribuables qui a donné des notes
et le département de la Marne comme qu
trois autres départements je crois à un
20/ 20 chose extraordinaire ça voudrait
dire quelque part peut-être que c'est un
un département bien géré en tout cas
c'est peut-être vu de la part des
contribuables et je me suis demandé si
vu de la part de l'État on arrivait à la
même satisfaction ce dont je ne suis pas
tout à fait sûr alors je savais que
j'avais depuis un certain temps un
budget bas c'est ancestral le
département de la Marne un département
moyen recette de fonctionnement par
habitant recette le cè de France alors
effectivement ça pose déjà un problème
les situations de rent ou les situations
de pénalité par rapport aux dotations de
l'État qui sont quand même un allément
important dans les budgets du
département étant donné qu'il y a
pratiquement plus de fiscalité et puis
d'autre part effectivement nous avons
des recettes basses parce que c'est la
réalité nous avons et depuis très
longtemps une fiscalité basse dans notre
département et en conséquence les
conséquences tiré par l'État dans ce
domainel c'est de pénaliser pénaliser
une collectivité qui n'a pas fait appel
à la fiscalité parce que elle a respecé
le contribuable donc quand vous êtes
attentif au prélèvement pris sur nos
citoyens vous êtes pénalisé par l'État
c'est quelque part interpellant surtout
quand vous avez les dépenses de
fonctionnement des plus basses donc ça
veut dire dépenses de fonctionnement
basse c'est 750 € par rapport à une
moyenne de 1000 € 25 % en dessous c'est
quoi c'est des dépenses bien sûr de
fonctionn
généraux de moyens généraux mais des
dépenses de personnel basses et des
dépenses sociales basses par tête
d'habitant ce qui veut dire monsieur le
ministre qu'on peut faire une politique
sociale ce qui veut dire que le
département et le bon échelon pour mener
une politique sociable supportable par
le contribuable et je pense qu'il se
fait un certain nombre de choses pour
est c'est qu'on a des ratios en ce qui
concerne l'hébergement pas l'hébergement
mais le placement de nos enfants en
crèche ou en structure en structure
famille mdiale ou collective des ratios
auudessus de la moyenne nationale en ce
qui concerne les personnes âgées aussi
comme quoi on peut faire une politique
sociale c'est pour ça qu'il faut être
attentif aux répartitions de de
compétences mais sur le plan de
l'investissement je suis bas par par
rapport à d'autres département et j'ai
20/ 20 là aussi dans les dépenses
d'investissement donc j'ai creusé un
petit peu pour j'avais cette note par
rapport à cela notamment par rapport à
l'iser elle a 10 sur 20 l'iser ah mais
c'est pas pour autant oui 10 sur 20 vous
avez 10 20 sur le classement des le
classement des des contribuables alors
j'ai la feuille HE je raconte pas des
bobards je l'ai pas prise là mais sur le
classement des des des contribuables
Associés hein mais c'est pas pour autant
que c'est pas pour autant que la gestion
de l'iser que les choses soient claires
entre nous est une mauvaise gestion
parce que c'est selon les critères hein
que non non je
suis les choses sont claires les choses
sont vous dire simplement parce que je
vois que le temps tourne je vous dire
simplement qu'en investissement ayant un
taux d'endettement de moitié moindre des
autres départements comme d'ailleurs euh
euh d'autres départements ici
représentés notre vous également où vous
êtes très faiblement endetté et bien là
aussi ça veut dire qu'on investit à
hauteur de nos moyens c'est pour ça
qu'on a 20/ 20 on n'a pas vécu au-dessus
de nos moyens et la corollaire monsieur
le ministre c'est que dans les détations
et dans les péréquations nous sommes
fait pénalyser parce qu'on dit
clairement dans le critère endettement
si vous n'êtes pas fortement end vous
pouvez faire appel à la dette comme vous
pouvez faire appel à la fiscalité et en
conséquence vous êtes moins aidé donc il
faudra quelque part changer un petit peu
de paradigme jusqu'à présent on était
sur un logiciel aide-toi le ciel
t'aideera qui conclut et c'est le modèle
du 20e siècle à ce que on ait une
inflation fiscale ou une inflation de
dette ça ne peut pas continuer comme ça
notre pays est déjà surendetté d'un côté
et nos et nos citoyens on ont assez de
payer de l'impôt en conséquence il
faudra véritablement changer de logiciel
par rapport aux lois àendre pour le
financement de nos collectivités
départementales deuxième point pourquoi
les départements vont-ils être en
faillite et Jean leson d pont l'a déjà
annoncé en faillite ça veut dire en
déficit de fonctionnement comptable dans
les années qui viennent bien pourquoi
parce qu'il y a un certain nombre de
décisions qui méritent d'être appelé la
décentralisation notamment avec les
compétences sociale ce sont 10 % de plus
par an sur le budget de fonctionnement
tous les ans en 30 ans de
décentralisation 300 % de charges de
fonctionnement supplémentaire pour les
départements ce qui montre bien que là
aussi il y a parallèlement une
diminution de l'autofinancement derrière
et une répercussion sur le budget les
décisions parisienne je n'y reviens pas
insupportable quand on modifie les
conventions collectives ça se traduit
automa ement par des surcharges au
niveau des collectivités départementales
quand on modifie Éric deliger le sait
bien les heur de garde des sapeurs
pompiers
professionnels répercussion par des
embauches supplémentaires toujours sur
les finances départemental et toutes les
dépôes imposées je rappelle les rythmes
scolaires je rappelle la décision prise
par le Premier ministre précédent de
pour de plus pour les bénéficiaires de
RSA je ne critique pas la mesure sauf
qu'elle s'implique sur le budget des
artemental avec toutes les conséquences
que cela peut avoir donc on voit bien
que derrière cela il y a automatiquement
une diminution de la capacité
d'autofinancement qui fait qu'elle
diminue chaque année et que va arriver
dans l'année 2015 2016 ou 2017 pour
l'ensemble des départements un déficit
de fonctionnement qui ne pourra pas être
longtemps subi par ces départements et
qui va particulièrement pénaliser
derrière derrière notamment
l'investissement donc il faudrait à la
fois arrêter la diminution de la
diminution de dotation de globale de
fonctionnement cette diminution pour les
départements devient insupportable
d'autant que les départements
contribuent notamment à l'effort de
solidarité par l'absence de compensation
des euh l'absence de compensation des
allocations de la solidarité et puis
peut-être monsieur le ministre modifier
aussi les règles compatables est-il
normal que l'on amortisse les
subventions d'investissement que l'on
donne aux communes ça rentre dans les
règles comptbl ce qui modifie la
structuration budgétaire et qui fait que
derrière ça précipite les départements
en déficit de
fonctionnement comptable et d'autre part
revenir à des bons principes qui décide
paye on peut pas continuer comme ça avec
des décisions nationales et des
implications locales le décideur doit
être le payeur sinon on va arriver
effectivement à l'asphixie des
départements et puis le troisième point
et j'en finis là c'est le coup de grâce
le cooup de grâce monsieur le ministre à
travers la loi nôre si vous persistez à
faire en sorte que la gestion de
proximité et je pense aux routes
notamment ne soit plus confié cette
gestion au département vous allez
accélérer ce déficit de fonctionnement
il ne se passera plus rien sur les
territoires d'autre part je vous
rappelle que compte tenu de la
proposition que vous faites faites sur
votre loi de transfert des financements
des routes c'est pareil pour le
transport scolaire vous
transférez de l'argent une dépense pour
le département qui devient une recette
pour la région de façon chronique et
plus vous avez bah si c'est comme ça le
principe de la loi de transfert des
routes l'argent du département qui va en
région ah bah écoutez c'est comme ça
c'est pas encore fait mais au jour
d'aujourd'hui soyons attentif oui mais
je vois bien que vous passez tout ça
après les élections hein quelque part on
peut se demander s'il y a pas une
arrière-pensée quand même hein ça veut
dire que ceux qui ont investi ceux qui
ont investi vont transférer plus
d'argent que les collectivités qui n'ont
pas fait leur travail et qui transfèrre
moins d'argent et c'est ceux qui on vont
payer ne sont pas ceux qui recevront
derrière des réalisations sur la
patrimoine donc l'affaire est mal
embarquée c'est la raison monsieur le
ministre et j'en finis là que
pour laquelle les
départements peuvent être une structure
de proximité qui ve peuvent refaire
partir la relance économique très
rapidement dès l'instant où il y a
quelques mesures qui sont prises et
permettre à nos concitoyens d'avoir des
services au meilleur coût avec la
meilleure organisation c'est pas tout à
fait ce qui nous est proposé
actuellement à travers notamment la loi
l'autre je vous remercie
bravo
alors dans la suite du débat la parole
est à notre collègue monsieur Vincent de
la monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers
collègues je me me réjouis de
l'initiative qui a été prise par le
groupe udiuc par le groupe UMP de ce
débat sur les finances départementales
après le débat que nous avons eu il y a
quelques semaines sur les finances
locales les finances départementales
connaissent
effectivement des problèmes généraux qui
sont ceux aussi des finances locales
prises dans leur ensemble des recettes
fiscales propres qui sont archaïques une
baisse drastique des dotations une
augmentation des charge obligatoire avec
toutefois pour les départements des
spécificités je pense bien entendu à
l'incertitude actuelle sur le périmètre
des compétences et des missions qui sont
dévolues au
département aussi commençons avec un peu
de légèreté le changement de nom du
Conseil Général en conseil départemental
a été initié par la loi de de 2013 qui a
inauguré le désormais bien connu binôme
départemental quoi de plus anodin qu'un
changement de nom ce n'est pas compliqué
à intégré dans un
texte pourtant bilan des opérations
entre 2 et 3 millions d'euros de
dépenses nouvelles pour les départements
qui vont devoir assumer le coût des
travaux des mises à jour des sites
internet et toutes les mesures rendues
nécessaires par cette coquetterie
législative c'est un exemple parmi
d'autres la réalité est la suivante les
départements à l'instar de l'ensemble
des autres collectivités territoriales
passe clairement pour les dindons de la
farce de ce que certains appellent
encore Pact de
responsabilité force est de constater
que la politique de maîtrise de la
dépense publique initiée il y a un peu
moins d'un an par le gouvernement repose
en réalité presque exclusivement sur la
réduction des dotations de l'État aux
collectivités cette première injustice
se couvre d'un manteau
d'incertitude face à ce mystérieux acte
3 de la décentralisation que plus
personne ne auquel plus personne ne
comprend
rien l'incompréhension et l'incertitude
sont telles que l'on ne sait plus si le
gouvernement souhaite supprimer les les
départements ou les conseils
départementaux ou s'ils souhaitent
encore revoir leurs compétences une fois
que le projet de loi nôre sera
adopté en en réalité il n'y a qu'une
seule certitude aujourd'hui les
départements ont été fragilisés à un
point peut-être jamais atteint ils ont
été fragilisés politiquement ils ont été
fragilisés financièrement aussi bien en
recette qu'en
dépenses les charges des départements
n'ont jamais été aussi lourdes
généraliste malgré lui de la politique
sociale le département a été frappé de
plein fouet par l'ampleur de la crise
économique et du
chômage de fait nos 101 départements
supportent les 9 milliards d'euros
représentés par le RSA socle c'est donc
un peu moins de 90 millions d'euros par
collectivité qui peut croire aujourd'hui
que ces dépenses vont
diminuer face à la situation économique
gravissim dans le dans laquelle notre
pays se trouve avec plus de 5 millions
de personnes sans emploi il est évident
que ces dépenses vont structurellement
évoluer à la
hausse à ce titre je m'inquiète
particulièrement de la nouvelle prime
d'activité présenté un peu à la vavite
par le gouvernement dans le dernier
dernier
PLFR cette prime qui a vocation à
remplacer le RSA et la prime pour
l'emploi a encore un champ d'application
très
flou je pense que c'est une des
caractéristiques de nos textes actuels
le flou en général et je crains que son
champ ne soit le champ de cette prime
d'activité de soit encore élargi rendant
le coût global encore plus lourd pour
nos
territoires on aimerait savoir Monsieur
le Ministre qui pra si on étend la prime
d'activité est-ce que les départements
seront mis à
contribution il ne faut pas oublier non
plus d'autres dépenses particulièrement
dynamiques ces dépenses sont d'autant
plus structurelles qu'elles sont liées
non pas à la conjoncture économique mais
à notre démographie je je pense bien
évidemment au financement de l'AP et de
Laah à ce titre je regrette que le
projet de loi relatif au vieillissement
ne permettent pas d'analyser l'impact
financier de la hausse du nombre de nos
seniors frappés par la dépendance sur
les budgets des départements qui seront
une fois de plus en première
ligne ces dépenses celles liées au
statut de chef de file en matière de
politique sociale représentent plus de
la moitié des budgets des départements
c'est un poste colossal c'est un poste
dynamique et ce n'est pas un poste
unique j'aurais pu évoquer les
compétences en matière de lutte contre
la précarité énergétique ou encore le
financement des collèges des 100000
personnels TOS ou encore les compétences
culturelles sans bien évidemment oublier
la gestion de nos routes
départementales évidemment les dépenses
départementales souffrent des mêmes
soucis que les autres collectivités et
je pense principalement à l'évolution
des coûts de
fonctionnement le dernier rapport de la
Cour des comptes relatif aux finances
locales a été particulièrement sévère
sur ce point les dépenses de
fonctionnement auraient ainsi depuis
1983 augmenté de plus de 3 % en moyenne
par an
elles augmente sensiblement plus vite
que les recettes mais à qui la
faute nous savons tous à quel point la
masse salariale est rigide du fait de
son statut principalement
public nous savons tous à quel point
cette masse salariale est dynamique
également entre la hausse des cotisation
retraite la revalorisation des
catégories BC la garantie individuel de
pouvoir d'achat le glissement vieillesse
technicité les contributions de
formations CNFPT la hausse de la part
employeur de la cotisation retraite et
même la hausse de la
TVA qui freine de fait les décisions
d'investissement il n'est plus rare de
trouver des départements qui ne
maîtrisent même plus 20 % de leur
budget j'aimerais pouvoir dire qu'un
important effort de gestion serait
suffisant pour palier à ces dépenses
contraintes en hausse mais
malheureusement même les bons
gestionnaires sont désormais pris au
piège face à un florilège de compéten
particulièrement lourdes les recettes ne
sont clairement pas au
rendez-vous pour synthétiser les choses
nous pourrions dire que la politique
sociale décidée par l'État et exécutée
par les départements est financée sur
une fiscalité archaïque assise sur la
dynamique du marché immobilier et par
une palette de taxes plus ou moins
fiscale allant de la taxe sur les
conventions d'assurance jusqu'à la
TIPP jusqu'en 2011 nous avons vécu avec
l'idée que les droits de mutation
étaient tellement dynamiques qu'il
justifiait finalement que le
gouvernement ne prête pas un grand
crédit aux appels et au signaux envoyés
par les présidents de Conseils Généraux
quelle erreur
d'analyse lorsque l'on sait que la taxe
sur le foncier bâti est la seule
ressource fiscale sur laquelle le
Conseil général a encore un véritable
pouvoir de
et bien évidemment nous savons tous à
quel point le secteur du bâtiment et de
l'immobilier se porte bien depuis
l'adoption de la loi du flot ditite
allure qui restera l'un des plus beaux
exemples du mal que peut faire une
mauvaise loi sur une économie
fragile nous avons donc des dépenses
naturellement en hausse des recettes peu
dynamiques et des dotations en
baisse cela ne devait manifestement pas
être suffisant puisque le gouvernement
séit virtué dès l'année dernière à
pimenté encore un peu plus la gestion
départementale en jetant un voile de
défiance sur l'avenir des
départements en effet les annonces et
contreannonces successives sur la
disparition des conseils généraux ont
achev de donner au département l'image
classique du bateau qui sombre dans
l'abîe une telle campagne de
communication avec un tel caractère
d'léire n'a pas été sans
conséquence en effet comment vous
voulez-vous souscrire un empreunt
bancaire quand vous représentez un
exécutif local dont l'existence est
menacée à moyen
terme les emprunts toxique ont déjà
donné une mauvaise image de la gestion
financière locale la date de péremption
inscrite au fronton de l'ensemble des
conseils départementaux achèvera de
convaincre les banques de systématiser
les primes de risque pour le financement
des investissements départementaux
idem en matière de ressources
humaines on ne monte pas dans un bateau
qui coule on le fuit comment voulez-vous
parvenir à une saine gestion des de vos
ressources humaines si vous savez qu'il
n'y a pas d'avenir dans l'administration
du
département enfin et c'est peut-être le
plus grave comment convaincre nos
concitoyens d'aller voter les dimanches
22 et 29 mars prochain pour des
élections non plus cantonnales mais
départementales qui attiraent déjà peu
les électeurs avant et qui les
attireront sans doute encore moins dès
lors qu'ils auront le sentiment qu'ils
élisent davantage des liquidateurs de
leur ancien conse conseil général que de
véritables décideurs de
proximité la loi nôtre étant toujours en
discussion les électeurs vont élire de
nouveaux conseillers sans même connaître
leurs futures compétences c'est un
nonsens démocratique monsieur le
ministre à trop vouloir faire du
département le parent pauvre de la
décentralisation vous risquez de
conduire les futurs exécutifs
départementaux dans le mur d'une
véritable rupture démocratique prélude à
une rupture de service public et et cela
c'est tout simplement
inacceptable il faut clairement dire où
l'on va et le dire vite monsieur le
ministre nous manquons de clarté
l'action départementale doit avoir une
perspective on ne peut pas priver les
départements de leur avenir sans
fragiliser toute la politique sociale et
la démocratie
participative à forceorie on ne peut pas
non plus tout leur faire porter non plus
les transferts permanents de compétences
couplés à des fin financement
parafiscaux archaïqu ne peuvent plus
durer il faut trouver des ressources
pérennes au département c'est un
impératif d'autant plus urgent que les
dotations ont baissé baissent et
continueront de le faire l'année
prochaine et l'année
suivante ce phénomène est d'autant plus
problématique que plus les difficultés
des départements s'accroisseront plus
ces derniers auront tendance à imputer
leurs problèmes aux autres échelons
locaux bientôt les départements ne
seront plus en mesure de verser des
subventions bientôt ils devront reporter
sur l'intercommunalité l'exercice réel
de nombreuses compétences ce qui ne
pourra donc que reporter le poids des
compétences que l'État ne veut plus
prendre directement en
charge quel bilan à ce stade je ne crois
pas être particulièrement alarmiste en
vous mettant en garde monsieur le
ministre la situation financière des
départements est critique ils seront
bientôt en situation de cessation de
paiement ça a été dit par les deux
précédents orateurs cela serait bien
évidemment dommageable pour nos
concitoyens au premier chef et pourtant
à l'heure actuelle je ne vois pas
d'issue
immédiate on nous parle d'une éventuelle
réforme de la DGF lors de la prochaine
loi de finances mais le moment est-il le
bienvenu je n'en suis pas convaincu une
réforme de cette ampleur est déjà
compliqué dans une période ordinaire
alors en pleine tempête financière pour
nos collectivités vous imaginez à quel
point cela va être
délicat face à cela nos territoires
attendent des réponses pour l'heure nous
n'en avons pas de votre part monsieur le
ministre c'est pourquoi je remercie
d'autant plus vivement les groupes UMP
et uduc d'avoir proposé ce débat qui
doit nous permettre je l'espère de
tracer des perspectives d'avenir plus
encourageante je vous
remercie
la parole est à notre collègue Monsieur
Bruno
sidau monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues la
situation financière des conseils
départementaux mériterait bien plus
qu'un débat mais grâce au Sénat cette
question importante pour le quotidien de
nos concitoyens est clairement mis sur
la table au sein de l'Association des
départements de France avec mes
collègues du groupe de la droite du
centre et des indépendants nous
formulons depuis plusieurs années le
même constat bien que nous soyons
enampagne électorale pour les élections
départementales j'ai assez de mémoire et
de franchise pour reconnaître que les
difficultés existaiit déjà avant mai
2012 afin que chacun compréenne bien le
sens de mon propos je précise d'emblé
que le gouvernement a raison de vouloir
réaliser des économies que c'est
clairement l'intérêt national d'y
parvenir aussi rapidement et massivement
que possible mon intervention mes chers
collègues n'aura donc rien
d'électoraliste malgré le contexte
politique entrons sans plus tarder dans
le vif du sujet le problème est est au
final assez simple les gouvernements ont
transféré aux collectivités des
compétences s leur donner les moyens de
les assumer je pense en ce qui concerne
les départements évidemment et en
premier lieu au domaine social
l'accompagnement des personnes âgées
avec la location personnalisée
d'autonomie en 2001 l' pas le soutien
aux personnes handicapées avec la
prestation de compensation du handicap
en 2005 la solidarité envers les
personnes en rupture d'insertion avec le
revenu de solidéré active en 2008 je
n'oublie pas la protection de l'enfance
don volet dont le volet relatif aux
mineurs isolés étrangers a pris un
relief singulier depuis
2013 sur les trois premières prestations
qui représentent l'essentiel du budget
de fonctionnement des conseils généraux
nos collectivités n'interviennent ni sur
les critères d'attribution ni sur les
montants ni sur les durées de versement
autrement dit en application de la loi
nous versons des prestations nationales
pour le compte de l'État ni plus ni
moins nous sommes donc dans la capacité
d'effectuer des économies sur ce champ
de compéten notre seule marge de
manœuvre se situe sur le personnel
d'instruction des dossiers et de suivi
des personnes bénéficiaires de ces aides
bref sur les travailleurs sociaux nous
avons des gains de productivité à
réaliser par l'information des
l'informatisation des données mais ils
ne permettent pas d'arriver à la hauteur
de l'enjeu nous nous en sommes très très
loin chaque année l'écart entre ce que
les départements dépensent à ce titre et
les recettes qu'ils perçoivent de l'État
pour y faire face
est estimé à un chiffre compris entre 5
et 6 milliards d'euros ce constat est
partagé par l'ADF comme par l'État
j'étais d'ailleurs hier soir à Matignon
avec Monsieur le Premier Ministre qui
anticipe une augmentation de 7 à 8 % du
nombre de bénéficiire du RSA plus
exactement de la dépense de RSA pour une
simple raison les droits au chômage
s'éteignent après 24 mois dans la
plupart des cas pour celles et ceux qui
n'ont pas retrouvé d'emploi et parce que
Monsieur le Premier Ministre a
conscience que cette situation ne peut
plus durer pour les finances
départementales il m'a annoncé la mise
en place prochaine après les élections
cantonales d'un groupe de travail sur le
sujet j'espère que c'est pas pour
enterrer le sujet bien entendu la
conséquence de cette situation mais
monsieur le ministre nous en parlera
tout à l'heure bien probablement la
conséquence de cette situation est
double et très logique la baisse de
l'investissement publics les
départements devant sacrifier une part
des dépenses d'avenir pour faire face à
leurs obligation et la hausse de
l'endettement comme l'a dit Monsieur
Savari malgré les dispositifs mis en
place je pense notamment au fond
diakerman introduit par le loi de
finances pour 2014 c'est permettez-moi
l'expression côtaire sur jambe de bois
en raison de la crise économique et du
vieillissement de la population les
dépenses sociales augmentent chaque
année les conseils départementaux n'ont
plus les moyens de faire face à la
situation l'État doit enfin prendre ses
responsabilités soit il maintient la
générosité du système de prestation et
attribue au département les moyens
nécessaires soit il effectue les
ajustements requis pour destiner aux
personnes âgées démunies et à ceux qui
en ont réellement le plus besoin
l'essentiel des moyens
disponible le refus de décider n'est pas
responsable et entraîne nos
collectivités dans le mur au détriment
Infiné des personnes les plus en
difficulté au travers cet exemple bien
connu je je souhaite mettre et mettre en
évidence le lien de causalité existant
entre le désengagement de l'État qui
essaie de faire des économie avec
beaucoup de bonne volonté et
l'alourdissement des dépenses des
collectivités qu'elle les finance par la
baisse de l'investissement public en
pénalisant l'activité du secteur de
secteur entier comme le bâtiment ou les
travaux publics ou ce qui est pire à mon
sens parce que cela cache le problème
sous le tapis par
l'emprunt les conseils généraux ont par
ailleurs été très très impacté par la
baisse des concours de l'état de 11
milliards d'euros si je partage
l'objectif d'économie auquel les
conseils départementaux sont associés je
souhaite que nous puissions enfin sortir
de l'impasse financière à l'exception du
champ social les collectivités sont
nombreuses à avoir engagé les
mutualisations nécessaires à la baisse
durable des dépenses de fonctionnement
par exemple dans le département de la
Haute Marne le service départemental
d'incendie et de secours le
finalise avec le conseil général une
convention qui permettra dans des prop
dans des prochains mois de créer des
services unifié dans les domaines des
finances des bâtiments ou des
transmissions par exemple de même nous
avons mis en place une plateforme
commune d'appel partagé entre le 15 et
le 18 au bénéfice des habitants qui sans
cela auraiit vu partir le centre d'appel
du Samu dans un département limitrophe
cependant je mesure chaque jour Monsieur
le ministre je mesure chaque jour les
résistances et les efforts à déployer
pour surmonter les réticences voire la
mauvaise volonté croyez-moi les élus et
certains préfets agissent de concert
dans la même direction mais la routine
et les habitudes de l'administration
sont un frein puissant après avoir
exposé brièvement un diagnostic
largement partagé permettez-moi de
formuler quelques préconisations en
complément de la l'appel à généraliser
les mutualisations et de la nécessité
pour l'État d'assumer enfin la
responsabilité des politiques sociales
qu'il nous impose tout d'abord une étude
d'impact devrait être réalisée pour
distinguer les bonnes économies des
mauvaises celles qui produisent des
dommage sur le tissu économique et
social de celles qui sont relativement
indolor ainsi peut-être eutt-il mieux
valu conserver le principe du non
remplacement d'un fonctionnaire sur deux
même pour nos collectivités tout en M
maintenant l'effort d'investissement
public des régions des départements ou
des communes ensuite serait-il vraiment
sacrilège d'engager avec les syndicats
de la fonction publique une discussion
pour définir ensemble les grands
principes d'un complément de
rémunération variable en fonction des
économies réalisées dans chaque service
à cadre de compéten Constant nous avons
d'excellents managers dans la fonction
publique CAPA d'organiser leurs équipes
de manière encore plus efficiente avec
le souci constant de la dépense et du
service public la mise en œuvre d'un tel
mécanisme permettrait d'identifier les
bonnes pratique et de récompenser le
mérite au service de l'intérêt général
enfin le périmètre de la sphère publique
lui-même pose question un service au
public ne peut-il pas être rendu avec
efficacité par le secteur privé sous le
contrôle de l'État bien entendu ou des
collectivités locales faut-il
nécessairement que les tâches
d'exécution soient tout par des agents
publics en raison du carcan
administratif le talent de nos agents
reste trop souvent sous-employés alors
que les professionnel du secteur privé
bénéficiant d'un cadre plus souple
dispose d'une plus grande liberté pour
déterminer l'organisation la plus
optimale à même d'atteindre les
objectifs de service public j'ai entre
parenthèses des exemples très précis à
donner parce qu'en période de crise
notre responsabilité est d'innover pour
réussir à faire aussi bien voir mieux
mux avec des ressources moindres je
propose que le Sénat mette en place une
mission d'information sur les bonnes
pratiques constatées en France et en
Europe sans tabout ni dogmatisme avec
pour seul objectif la réussite
collective je propose aussi à l'heure où
le rôle du Sénat est en débat de
favoriser un bicamérisme complémentaire
qui limiterait les prérogatives parfois
excessives de l'administration grâce à
une mesure simple accordé aux
commissions permanentes du Sénat le
droit de coécrire avec le gouvernement
les décrets d'application des lois à
l'instar de ce qui se passe chez nos
voisins allemands en d'autres termes un
droit de contrôle de la conformité des
décrets d'application à l'esprit et à la
lettre de la loi car mes chers collègues
qui d'autre que nous a vraiment à cœur
de servir la simplification
administrative qui d'autre pourrait
veiller non seulement à lapparution
rapide des décrets d'application à leur
fidélité par rapport au texte de loi
mais surtout tout à l'esprit d'économie
alors que certains à l'Assemblée
nationale rêvent de bundesratiser le
Sénat pardonnez-moi cette expression je
pense que cette évolution leur
réserverait bien des surprises je vous
remercie la parole est à notre collègue
Monsieur Thierry
kenac
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues évoquer la
situation financière des conseils
départementaux n'est pas une nouveauté
inconnue du gouvernement le rapport
annuel de l'Observatoire du Comité des
finances locales retrace la situation
financière des départements la Cour des
comptes dans son rapport public annuel
de 2013 avait réalisé un état d'élu
approfondi relatif au déficit de
financement des allocations
individuelles de solidarité pour les
départements du à un décalage croissant
entre recette affectées et charges lié
et pour 2010 la Cour des comptes estimé
le décalage à 9 milliards d'euros elle
estimé en 2013 que le statut quo
financier n'était plus possible et le
dernier rapport connu caresto du 20 mai
2010 avait fixer un diagnostic à la
veille du gel des dotations de l'État
aux collectivité local pour la période
2011-23 dans ses conclusions ce rapport
évoqué pour les départements un effet de
ciseau dû à la croissance des dépens
social obligatoire et à l'évolution
divergente des ressources et des
dépenses il indiquit que le reste à
charge pour les départements dont la
dynamique est inquiétante deviendrait
une vraie difficulté par le gel des
dotations depuis les dépenses des
allocations individuelles de solidarité
la pas lié à la croissance de la
démographie des plus de 60 15 ans le
revenu de solidarité active lié à la
dégradation de l'emploi en lien avec le
marché du travail dégradé et au plan de
lutte contre lav la pauvreté voulue par
le président de la République la
loocation a été majorée et sera majorée
de 10 % a vu une évolution de plus 7 %
en 2013 et de plus 10 % en 2014 du RSA
la montée en charge de la prestation de
compassation du handicap n'ont cessé de
progresser à un rythme très net
supérieur à l'inflation en 2013 les
dépenses dett sociales des départements
ont été de 34 milliards d'euros soit + 2
% par rapport à 2012 et plus 10 % par
rapport à 2009 sur un total de dépenses
de fonctionnement hors intérêt de la
dette de près de 60 milliards la
répartition territoriale des dépenses
d'action sociale est assez inégale et
varie de 350 € par habitant à 800 € en
fonction de la situation des
départements l'effort demandé aux
collectivités locales pour redresser les
finances de la France ne fera
qu'emplafierier le phénomène la
contribution demandée au département est
de 1 Millard
15 en 2015 au total sur
2014-207 la baisse s'élèvera à 3
millards
pour les départements nous avions
souhaité ici même l'étaler sur une année
supplémentaire les réponses apportées à
court terme deux réponses ont été
apportées pour les départements les plus
en difficulté par les gouvernements de
Monsieur Fillon et ho qui ont débloqué
dans l'urgence 75 millions d'euros
prélevés sur laassen Nessa en moyen
terme les gouvernements de monsieurs
Hero et Vals ont été les seuls à mettre
à disposition des départements sous
forme de fonds de compensation pcé les
frais de gestion de la taxe foncière sur
la propriété bâtie qui représente 841
millions d'euros l'an dernier et ouvert
la possibilité d'augmenter les droits de
mutation de 0,7 % pour 2 ans pour l'un
et de pérenniser cette possibilité pour
l'autre ce que nous avons voté à la fin
de l'année
90 départements ont utilisé cette
faculté en 2014 soit une ressource de
l'ordre de 800 millions d'euros par an
variable en fonction de la situation du
marché de l'immobilier néanmoins ce que
constate-t-on le financement des
allocations individuelles de de
solidarité conduit à un reste à charge
stabilisé à 7 milliards d'euros avec une
situation qui voit le RSA augmenter dans
des proportion inégalé + 9 % en 2013 +
10 % en 2014 avec une prévision
identique pour
2015 par ailleurs hors recette nouvelle
les produits de la CVAE ont baissé et C
de et ceux de la taxe foncière sur la
propriété bâti ont été légèrement en
hausse de plus 2,4 %. or la loi de
programmation des finances publiques
pour
2014-209 instaure un objectif
d'évolution des dépenses de
fonctionnement de 2 % et de 0,5 % de la
dépense locale en 2015 cette situation
est intenable pour les départements qui
n'ont plus de marge et qui ne peuvent
qu'envisager de réduire leurs
investissements et subventions aux
collectivités locales ce qui n'est pas
bon pour l'économiecal non délocalisable
des BTP et des travaux publics l'épargne
brute à pu être préservé en 2014 + 0,9 %
soit un total de 7 milliards environ
après 2 années de fortte baisse don - 13
% en 2012 grâce aux mesures déjà prises
l'épargne nette devient négative pour
quelques départements et se réduit de
plus en plus la réforme en cours des
compétences loin nôre va impacter la
structure des budgets départementaux qui
à la suite des transferts de compétences
on voir leur budget diminuer et le stock
de dette en proportion accroître
fragilisant un peu plus les départements
l'emprunt n'étant pas affecté et nous
pouvant être transféré dès lors la
réforme des dotations envisagé par le
gouvernement des 2016 qui voit notre
collègue jean-germain et Madame pirzbon
travailler en rapport sur la DGF devrait
concerner également les départements je
soulligne que la dernière réforme de la
DGF des départements remonte à 2005 elle
avait figé les inégalités et la
péréguation en période de gel des
dotations a eu un effet contre-productif
pour les départements d'ID desfavorisés
la nécessaire simplification des
dotations s'imposent les dispositifs de
péréquation horizontale et verticale
sont au nombre de 10 pour les
départements rendant illisible ces
dispositifs ainsi sur la DGF dans la
péréquation horizontale 100 département
bénéficie de la péréquation 40 urbain 60
ruraux hors Paris et les ou de scène qui
allont été exclus ainsi pour la région
en demid pyrénée les écarts sont très
importants par exemple entre le
département queoch connait bien du tard
et son voisin de laavyon c'est 80 € par
habitant de différence qui rapportter à
la population correspondent à 30
millions d'écart de dotation alors que
les critères de revenus des habitants et
le potentiel fiscal sont similaires
c'est bien ce que je disais c'est en
2005 la réforme a figé les inégalités et
on était sur à ce moment-là un potentiel
fiscal superficiaire la DGF va de 90 €
par habitant à 472 € par habitant hors
Paris outre mer en 2014 soit un écart de
1 à 5 les potentiels fiscaux varient
entre 205 € par habitant et 1040 € par
habitant un écart de 1 à 5 il convient
donc de réformer de façon plus équitable
la DGF en tenant compte notamment des
revenus des habitants de la densité de
population du réseau kilométrique de
voirie de la zone de montagne et de mise
en place d'une péréquation qui ne soit
pas contreperformante or lors du CFL du
27 février dernier la DG le le directeur
général des collectivités locales a
indiqué que de son point de vue la
réforme de la DGF des départements était
moins urgente que celle du bloc local
car la répartition de DGF est moins
contestée pour les départements et les
régions une mise en œuvre en 2017 paraît
donc trop tardive enfin j'ajoute que les
autres collectivités locales regardent
avec envie les 48,5 % de CVE affectés au
département alors quel devenir pour la
fiscalité des départements il me paraît
essentielle qu'un panier de dépenses
corresponde à un panier de ressources
dynamique dans cette attente des
rencontres thématiques devraient être
organisés entre le gouvernement et les
collectivités territoriales afin de
négocier une relation sereine entre
l'État et les départements
soit par une juste compensation des
dépenses d' loocation individuelle de
solidarité nationale soit par une
recentralisation de la dépense en ne
laissant au département que l'insertion
de proximité en relation avec l'État et
pour l'emploi ceci ne pourra être
possible que tout autant que soit étudié
une mesure d'urgence pour les
départements en difficulté confronté à
une hausse massive du RSA par un
dispositif transparent je pense par
exemple au fond de d'urg de la SNSA qui
avait été mis en place dans le passé
devant cette situation les départements
attendent une réponse d'urgence du
gouvernement pour cette année 2015 pour
atténuer comme indiqué l'augmentation
des allocations individuelles de
solidarité constaté en 2014 et qui va se
prolonger cette année je rappelle que
les recettes de la CSA de la Casa pardon
sont estimés à 682 millions pour 2015 et
que cet année elle pourrait être
peut-être utilisée en attendant
l'adoption de la loi de la société au
vieillissement je vous
remercie la parole est à notre collègue
madame Corine
bouchou monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues
euh nous constatons avec le débat qui
nous réunit cet après-midi sur la
situation financière des conseils
départementaux face à l'évolution de
leur charge que nous sommes face à ce
que certains collègues ont déjà nommé la
quadrature du cercle les dépenses vont
exploser et vont augmenter de plus en
plus pour des raisons démographiques
pour des raisons économiques et pour des
raisons de contexte les recettes sont
promises à une contraction drastique au
motif de lutter contre les déficits
publics et se pose du coup poser la
question du fonctionnement de nos
conseils départementaux et aussi de la
la marge qui restera pour d'éventuels
investissements qui sont quand même
indispensables si on veut maintenir un
minimum d'activité au plan local avant
d'aller plus loin je voudrais quand même
préciser que c'est une spécialité très
française qu'on avait par exemple vu à
l'œuvre lors de la loi pcres qui est de
transférer d'un acteur l'État vers un
autre collectif dans le cas d'espèce les
université des compétences et de ne pas
donner à l'équivalent le budget qui
permet de fonctionner en faisant une
analyse qui peut se tenir du point de
vue intellectuel et bien au plus proche
du terrain les acteurs font des
économies qu'on n' pas réussi à faire
vue de Paris c'est exactement la même
logique qui préside à ce qu'on constate
depuis un certain nombre d'années et
donc avec une grande constance quelle
que soit la sensibilité des
gouvernements qui se sont succédés cela
a été dit tout à l'heure par plusieurs
collègues nous sommes avec un effet de
ciseau tout à fait catastrophique hausse
des dépenses alors que les recettes sont
ou stabilisées ou en baisse comment
peut-on dans une telle perspective avoir
un espoir de nourrir un projet politique
pour le Conseil départemental parce que
c'est ça la réalité nous parlons
finances nous parlons budget nous
parlons impôts mais la réalité c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on veut faire de nos
territoires quelle vision voulons-nous
donner à nos citoyens et à cet égard
l'entrée par les masses budgétaire si
elle est indispensable et elle sera
sûrement précieuse à tous les candidats
qui ce soir vont regarder sur le site du
Sénat nos débat le débat que nous avons
là est une entrée par l'argent ça n'est
pas une une entrée par les projets ça
n'est pas non plus une entrée par la
gouvernance ce qui a été très absent des
débats de de de cet après-midi alors
comment est-ce que l'on pourrait essayer
d'améliorer les choses euh nous pensons
au niveau du groupe écologiste
qu'évidemment les évolutions qui sont en
cours de discussion encore aujourd'hui
concernant la loi nôre vont avoir un
rôle tout à fait déterminant on ne peut
pas continuer euh dans dans le dans le
flou artistique tel qu'il est un jour
les routes sont au département ensite le
lendemain elles sont à la région puis
elles reviennent au département et donc
dans cette situation extrêmement
instable la situation nous semble tout à
fait préoccupante alors nous vous le
savez peut-être dans notre famille
politique nous n'étions pas des ardents
défenseurs du département nous étions
plutôt pour des des métropo dynamique
des régions fortes et structurées et
l'échelon européen pour créer une sy
synergie à ce niveau-l
l'option qui a été choisie après celle
de dévitaliser le département a été de
le lui redonner quelqu énergie
malheureusement nous constatons que si
les compétences demeurent au département
au niveau des perspectives financières
il n'y a aucun espoir qui est laissé à
ces départements et cela nous semble
quand même particulièrement
préoccupant dernier point et cela a été
aussi signalé tout à l'heure c'est
évidemment la question de la DGF qui
doit être remise à plat qui est sans
cesse différée sauf erreur de ma part on
est encore sur les bases de 2005 donc
comment peut-on se projeter lorsqu'on a
pas une vision à 5 ans c'est quelque
chose d'extrêmement complexe et deuxième
point que je voudrais aborder aussi
c'est la question des ayant droits et
des bénéficiaires ma collègue Aline
archimbau a rendu un rapport qui a été
extrêmement remarqué à l'époque sur les
différents motifs de la pauvreté et qui
indiquait que 50 % des personnes en
situation de pauvreté n'utilisent pas
les droits auxquels elles pouvaient
prétendre par par mes connaissances ou
pour tout un tas de raison si on imagine
ce qui nous a été promis qu'on va
améliorer l'information de nos publics
les plus pauvres des plus précaire si on
va améliorer leur information quant à
leur droit nous allons avoir une
augmentation en plus supplémentaire des
bénéficiaires de toutes les allocations
que nous avons cité la PA le revenu de
solidarité active et évidemment la
prestation de compensation du handicap
et donc la question qui se pose à nous
c'est et c'est le point de vue que je
voulais défendre devant vous pour les
écologistes c'est qu'on ne peut pas
isoler la question sur les masses
budgétaires et vous avez raison bah de
regretter la baisse des des dotations
qui va poser problème mais la question
que nous voulons poser est celle de la
gouvernance c'est-à-dire c'est la façon
dont on va au niveau de l'échelon
départemental réfléchir à l'avenir
comment éviter de reproduire les erreurs
sur les empreuns toxiques comment éviter
de reproduire quand même un certain
nombre de construction pharaonique que
nous avons fait et que parfois nous
contestons c'est-à-dire quel regard
critique sur ce qui a été fait il y a
peut-être des choses à faire mieux et à
faire autrement et la dernière question
qui nous préoccupe beaucoup c'est
l'égalité entre les territoires alors si
nous regardons là y compris le rapport
de la Cour des comptes et les
statistiques nous sommes dans une
situation qui non seulement est
préoccupante et dramatique mais qui est
aussi extrêmement inégalitaire en
fonction de la distance qui sépare un
habitant d'une métropole en fonction du
contexte géographique et en fonction
également par exemple de données
climatiques je pense au contexte par
exemple dans dans qui peut peuvent se
poser en en montagne pour tout dire il
nous semble extrêmement important de
d'arrêter de façon la plus précise
possible les compétences et à partir du
moment où on aura arrêté définitivement
les compétences des conseils
départementaux et bien d'envisager
autrement la gouvernance l'exercice des
responsabilités les choix des
investissements et dernier point le plus
crucial les personnels vous savez
qu'actuellement les personnels des
conseillers généraux sont sont
extrêmement inquiets la situation que
nous leur imposons est stressogène ils
sont au contact des plus démunis et des
plus faibles et en
plus on ne leur donne pas d'avenir et
pas de perspective donc pour toutes ces
raisons nous espérons monsieur le
ministre que vous pourrez répondre à ces
inquiétude et surtout nous dire à quand
une véritable réforme de la DGF et à
quand une vision stabilisée pour les
conseils départementaux parce que si
nous nous réjouissons du ticket qui
permettra c'est au moins la vertu de
cette élection d'avoir plus de femmes
dans les exécutifs des conseils
départementaux on est quand même un pays
unique au monde où on va voter dans 3
semaines en ne sachant pas ce qu'on va
dire aux électeurs c'est qu'on est
obligé de leur dire votez pour moi j'ai
des beaux projets j'ai des bonnes idées
mais je ne sais pas exactement ce que je
vais faire pour vous et je dirais que
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui est
très compliqué c'est compliqué et donc
on aimerait vos éclairages je vous
remercie de votre
attention la parole est à notre collègue
Monsieur Christian
Favier monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues la
situation financière des départements
mérite bien un débat au Sénat tant elle
est aujourd'hui alarmante c'est un sujet
majeur pour les habitants l'activité
économique les territoires depuis des
années les élus locaux avec leurs
associations l'Assemblée des
départements de France notamment ne
cesse de dénoncer l'effet ciseau généré
par l'écart croissant entre les dépenses
et les recettes budgétaires depuis des
années l'état contrairement à l'esprit
des dispositifs de décentralisation ne
compense plus intégralement les
transferts de compétences dans le même
temps les disposit les dispositions
initiées par les différents
gouvernements non cessé de réduire
l'autonomie financière des collectivités
particulièrement celle des départements
au point de les enfermer dans un carcan
qui est fragilise durablement
aujourd'hui la contribution de 11
milliards d'euros imposé aux
collectivités territoriales dans le
cadre du plan de réduction de 50
milliards de la dépense publique
s'ajoutant aux réductions déjà décidées
en 2014 conduit tout particulièrement
les départements dans une impasse
financière
généralisée les études évaluations
projet projection mené récemment que ce
soit l'initiative de nos collègues de la
délégation sénatoriale aux collectivités
territoriales et à la décentralisation
fin 2014 ou de l'ADF début 2015 pour ne
citerquel en atteste toute constate les
détériorations déjà visibles et
évoqueent démonstration à l'appui des
situations financières insoutenables à
court terme d'ors et déjà certains
départements ou communes ne sont pas
encore parvenus à équilibrer leur budget
2015 où le fond au prè d'une remise en
cause drastique de services publics
utiles aux habitants dans ce contexte
donc de régression des dotations de
l'état des départements sont
particulièrement touchés par la
conjonction de trois facteurs d'abord
l'alu l'évolution des allocations
individuelles de solidarité dont l'État
a confié au département la charge sans
qu'il ne dispose d'une quelconque marge
de manœuvre puisque ces allocations on
le sait relèvent de normes nationales
parmi elles le revenu de solidarité
active le RSA connaît une évolution
considérable suivant la courbe du
chômage tandis que se creuse davantage
encore l'écart entre leur montant et les
compensations financières de l'État
comme en témoigne l'observatoire
national de l'action sociale la
croissance donc de la charge nette pour
les départements de l'allocation RSA est
saisissante je cite concrètement la
charge restant à financer par les
départements après compensation de état
s'élève à 200 millliard3 en 2013 alors
qu'elle était de 100illard5 l'année
précédente nous ne disposons pas encore
des données nationales 2014 mais dans
mon département dans le Valdemar l'an
dernier le versement de la du RSA a
connu une augmentation de 17 millions
d'euros d'ailleurs de plus de 8 %
passant de 192 millions d'euros à 209
millions d'euros et l'écart donc entre
les allocations versées et les
compensations de l'État at igne
maintenant et dépasse les 90 millions
d'euros au total le montant cumulé
annuellement des noncensations de l'État
donc aux allocations de solidarité il
atteint maintenant dans ce département
672 millions d'euros
soit le même ordre de grandeur que
l'encours global de notre
dette deuxème facteur de tension une
part non négligeable des recettes des
départements relève de ressources
fragiles car dépendant de la conjoncture
et de sur quoi
difficile à anticiper il s'agit des
droits de mutation de la taxe
d'aménagement ou de la CVAE cette
dernière créée donc remplacement de la
taxe professionnelle s'avère
particulièrement inéquitable et
imprévisible inéquitable à l'égard des
entreprises elles-mêmes car si elle a
très peu bénéficié au PME et TPE elle a
permis une économie globale de quelques
6 milliards d'euros dont on
principalement bénéficier les grandes
entreprises inéquitable à l'égard
également des territoires car
inégalement réparti elle représente
selon les départements un apport par
exemple de 37 à 400 € par habitant selon
les départements soit un rapport de 1 à
troisièmement les diverses réformes
intervenues progressivement
on progressivement privé nos
départements de leur autonomie fiscale
c'est particulièrement marquant depuis
la réforme de la taxe professionnelle de
2011 puisqu'il ne disposeement plus que
du levier du taux de la taxe bâti
aujourd'hui donc une grande partie des
départements est en grande difficulté
budgétaire y compris pour assumer leur
seul compétten obligatoire et donc il
est urgent de réorienter les choix qui
président donc à ces dangereuses
évolutions annoncées car tout cela a
conduit finalement à quoi certainement
pas à un redressement des comptes
publics de la nation la réalité montre
démontre que les coupes sombres déjà
opérés sur les finances des
collectivités n'ont pas empêché la
dégradation des finances publiques et de
la dette certainement pas non plus à une
amélioration des finances des
collectivités celle-ci faut-il le
rappeler sont globalement saines leur
budget obligatoirement équilibré et leur
endettement à ce jour est marginal par
rapport à celui de l'État en revanche
leurs lourdes contraintes budgétaire
tendent à dégrader rapidement leur taux
d'épargne brut et leur capacité de
désendettement et les menant au risque
de surendettement et de déséquilibre et
cela ne conduit pas non plus à une
amélioration de la situation économique
actuellement la plupart des
collectivités on le sait se trouve dans
l'obligation de réduire non seulement
l'emploi public mais aussi
l'investissement et impactant ainsi
gravement l'activité par exemple du BTP
où des centaines de milliers d'emplois
sont aujourd'hui en jeu enfin tout cela
ne favorise pas non plus le déploiement
et l'efficacité des services publics de
proximité l'augmentation du chômage de
la précarité la dégradation du pouvoir
d'achat de nombreuses familles appelle
non pas des réductions de services mais
au contraire davantage de solidarité
d'initiative et d'innovation publique
c'est donc bien la question d'une
réorientation radicale des choix
politiques et budgétaires qui est posé
pour préserver des capacité d'action de
nos départements dont aujourd'hui
heureusement peu de monde conteste
l'utilité sociale et économique ainsi le
RSA constitue pour les départements une
charge financière particulièrement
lourde en même temps ceci n'apporte pas
de plusvalue les départements n'apporent
pas de plusvalue ni de visibilité à ces
bénéficiaires dès lors pourquoi l'État
ne reprendrait-il pas intégralement la
gestion côté recette la redéfinition
d'un impôt économique plus juste et plus
transparent pourrait être engagé
encourageant l'emploi et le
développement solidaire des territoires
il pourrait être modulé en fonction de
la masse salariale et de la valeur
ajoutée des entreprises par ailleurs le
li le principe de la libre
administration des collectivités appelle
aussi leur établissement de leur
autonomie fiscale enfin rappelons que
les contraintes imposées aux
collectivités pourrai être largement
compensé par des dispositifs de justice
fiscale parmi lesquels l'instauration
d'une taxe de 05 % sur les actifs
financiers qui rapporteraient 30
milliards d'euros d'autres propositions
bien entendu mériteraient d'être
travaillé mais quoi qu'il en soit ell
dépendent on le sait de choix
d'orientation politique totalement
opposé soit l'état s'acharne sous la
pression de la Commission de Bruxelles à
s'inscrire dans ce processus dévastateur
de réduction de la dépense publique et
dans ce cas il confortera le système
actuel pesant fortement sur les
départements pour les obliger à
sacrifier leur politique publique malgré
quelques mesurettes marginal soit
s'affirme la volonté responsable mais
résolue de faire de l'action et des
investiss public des leviers de la
relance économique de la satisfaction
des besoins humains et du développement
des territoires cette orientation
suppose l'existence de collectivité de
proximité forte et reconnu dans leur
existence leurs compétences et leur
ressources c'est particulèrement vrai
pour les départements dont les missions
sont au cœur des cohésions sociales et
territorial et pour notre part pour
notre groupe nous nous inscrivons avec
détermination bien évidemment dans cette
seconde hypothèse
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Monsieur François
Fortassin monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers
collègues je vais commencer par la
situation de mon département et
notamment la façon dont été traité les
phénomènes
climatiques il y a eu des épisodes
neigeux qui sont intervenus surtout sur
le massif
pyrénéen et le conseil général et les
services du
département sont immédiatement
intervenus pour rétablir la
circulation de la même façon un village
été coupé en deux du fait d'un
glissement de terrain
et les quelques habitants qui étaient
prisonniers en définitive pendant
quelques jours ont pu regagner la vallée
et pouvoir bien entendu se ravitailler
cela a était
possible du fait de la proximité
qu'exercent les services du
département cette proximité elle est
indispensable que ce soit sur les routes
sur le problème du dénaigement et de la
même façon sur l'aide sociale certes
l'aide sociale vous nous la laissez
généreusement puisque personne n'en
veut mais il faudra que le le
gouvernement
m'explique quelle est la
logique qui
veut que les
routes doivent passer à la région
surtout lorsqu'il s'agit d'une région
qui va de Gavarni au au contrefort des
cesvines
car l'efficacité en la matière surtout
lorsqu'il y a des dérèglements
climatiques
elle ne se mesure qu'à une capacité
extrêmement rapide d'intervention et une
connaissance du terrain on ne pourra pas
demander à quelqu'un qui sera à Toulouse
ou à Montpellier de très bien connaître
les vallées
pyrénéennes proximité
efficacité ce sont des actions positives
reconnues alors l'autre interrogation
que
j'ai c'est de savoir
pourquoi unanimement de la droite à la
gauche on nous dit que les département
marche bien ils ont mis certes du temps
moi qui est connu la décentralisation
de
faire je sais qu'il y a eu un certain
nombre d'années pour se mettre en
quelque sorte au bout du jour mais
aujourd'hui tous les départements
fonctionnent bien pourquoi faut-il
détruire dans ce pays quelque chose qui
fonctionne
bien je pense telle est la question
quelle est la
logique qui a présidé à ce type
d'aberration et à titre personnel je ne
suis pas concerné puisque aussi bien
j'ai décidé après un mandat renouvelé
pendant 36 ans de ne pas me
représenter mais je me pose la question
de savoir ce que ces malheureux
candidats comme cela a été signalé vont
pouvoir dire à leurs
concitoyens durant la campagne
électorale en dehors du fait de dire
nous ferons pour le
mieux c'est tout ce qu'ils pourront dire
puisque nous connaissons sont pas les
compétences et s'il y avait encore une
ligne directrice
perceptible nous pourrions
comprendre cette ligne
directrice bien
identifi pour l'instant je ne l'ai pas
vu et puis il y a quand même ça je ne
vais pas résister à ce plaisir certaines
déclarations qui sont parfois assez
coccasses c'est ainsi par exemple que
Madame
Lebranchu déclaré il y a très peu de
temps que les départements avaient
toutes leurs pertinence et qu'il était
indispensable de les
conserver l'automne étant passé par là
les feuilles mortes sétant envolé
nous avons vu un changement
d'attitude extrêmement net mais qui est
loin de nous
satisfaire alors la situation financière
des
départements comme cela été dit
elle est assez
catastrophique baisse des dotations de
2014 à 2017 et elle est catastrophique
non point parce que subitement les
départements n'aurait pas géré avec la
pertinence qu'il a l'heure mais tout
simplement parce
que l'État n'est plus au rendez-vous
d'un certain nombre de dépenses qui nous
impose l'épargne brute a connu une
érosion continue dans même des
départements dans lesquels elle est
négative et la baisse de dotations
entraîne une dégradation ext exêmement
importante enfin la capacité de
désendettement qui était de 3 ans et
quelques il y a encore peu de temps et
qui serait d'après les
expertise de 17 an né en
2018 quand on est à ce niveau on n'est
pas loin de la
faillite et là nous avons de vives
inquiétudes des associations d'élus
notamment départementaux la Fédération
Nationale des Travaux publics ont
récemment demandé au gouvernement la
tenue dans les plus tél des assises de
l'investissement public local car il
faut quand même pas oublier que dans ce
pays les collectivités
territoriales assurent l'essentiel de
l'investissement et
l'investissement ce sont des
emplois des emplois pérennes mais encore
faut-il qu'il puisse y avoir qu' puisse
y avoir un
investissement
enfin l'autre élément qui est peut-être
le plus important j'ai évoqué tout à
l'heure monsieur le ministre la
difficultés qu'auront nos camarades et
amis pour aller faire campagne en ne
sachant pas exactement ce qu'ils ont
dans la
besacee c'est que les conseillers
généraux demain conseillers
départementaux
qui sont en permanence sur le terrain au
moins dans les zones rurales étit
souvent interrogés par leurs
concitoyens que vont-ils pouvoir leur
dire
demain le résultat est le suivant ils
vont y perdre à la fois leur autorité
leur crédibilité si ça n'est pas leur
dignité alors monsieur le
ministre vous et je sais que vous êtes
un spécialiste de la chose
départementale de nous donner la ligne
directrice qui a guidé l'action du
département
frois allez la parole est à notre
collègue Monsieur David
Racheline
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues à quelques jours des élections
ce débat mérite d'être pleinement
d'actualité malheureusement il est
également tronqué en effet on ne sait
pas de quoi on parle les charges qui
vont incomber au Conseil départementaux
sont à l'heure actuelle inconnu la loi
notre est encore en pleine discussion et
je n'ose imaginer qu'elle puisse rester
dans sa version actuelle tellement nos
collègues députés ont modifié ce texte
d'ailleurs les véritables objectifs du
gouvernement restent flous au mieux
monsieur le ministre vous ne savez pas
où vous allez au pire vous cachez au
français de nouvelle fois votre
véritable objectif objectif que l'on
sait dictter par Bruxelles objectif qui
est de faire disparaître les département
c'était d'ailleurs dans la première
version du projet de loi mais comme vous
avez compris que les Français étaient
attachés à cet héritage et que et que
vous n'auriez certainement pas la
capacité pour modifier la Constitution
vous avez changé de stratégie et choisi
une façon plus sournoise d'arriver à vos
fins d'un côté vous enlevez des
compétences au conseils départementaux
on ne sait pas encore lesquels mais si
j'en crois les discussions en cours à
l'Assemblé nationale elles seront
nombreuses et d'un autre vous diminuez
drastiquement les dotations financières
de ces mêmes conseils départementaux
ainsi ces conseils ayant moins de
responsabilité beaucoup moins de moyens
financiers vont perdre de leur pouvoir
perdre de leur capacité de faire de la
politique au sens premier du terme bref
ils vont devenir une coquille une
coquille vide qu'il sera ensuite facile
de faire disparaître or le département
est un marqueur de l'identité française
un outil de proximité un outil de
solidarité un outil de service public
aussi les départements sont également un
moyen de maintenir un équilibre dans la
diversité du territoire français
équilibre entre la ruralité et
l'urbanité pour revenir à la question
des finances en coupant les vivres au
département au motif de faire des
économies économies qui soit soitd en
passant sont rendu nécessaires du fait
de vos politiques désastreuses que vous
avez misise en place depuis des années
vous les empêchez de mener les
politiques de de de proximité qui manque
tempant au français il est clair qu'il y
a des économies à faire dans les
conseils départementaux je pense
notamment notamment aux dépenses de
communication aux subventions en tout
genre qui servent plus souvent le
clientélisme que le que le bien commun
un peu moins de communication et plus
d'action voilà un programme que nous
souhaitons voir mettre en œuvre dans les
départements il faut également lutter
contre la fraude dont sont victimes les
département en tant que distributeur de
nombreuses prestations sociales je pense
notamment au RSA mais malgré ces pistes
d' omie la situation financière des
départements dû d'une part à une
mauvaise gestion des donniers publics
par vos amis et d'autre part dû à la
baisse des dotations de l'État va
obliger ses collectivités de proximité à
baisser leurs investissements et cela va
fortement ça a été dit impacter le tissu
de PME qui maille notre territoire mais
c'est sans doute ce que vous cherchez
favoriser les grandes régions sans
identité favoriser les métropoles sans
les campagnes et favoriser les grands
groupes sans les PME la situation
financière des conseils départementaux
est difficile mais mais ce qui est plus
grave c'est la situation des conseils
généraux aujourd'hui départementaux
demain tout court sur pression de
Bruxelles ils sont sur la Cellette nous
nous sommes viscéralement attachés au
triptique commune département état et
luttons contre votre vision UMPS
intercommunalité grande région Union
européenne même s'il faut le reconnaître
dans cette Haute Assemblée vous êtes
nombreux et surtout les bancs il faut
bien le dire avoir cette vision commune
département état des collectivités
territoriales heureusement au moins on
peut dire monsieur le ministre que vous
êtes pour une fois clairvoyant et
cohérent étant donné la claque
électorale que vous êtes sur le point de
prendre aux élections départementales
vous supprimer les départements c'est
une curieuse conception de la démocratie
représentative mais cela illustre bien
votre absence de vision pour la France
ou plutôt vision dicté par Bruxelles
mais prenez garde à ce rythme vous allez
bientôt être obligé de faire disparaître
toutes les
institutions la parole est à notre
collègue monsieur GUID Dominique
Kenel monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je crains
d'être redondant par rapport à la
plupart des orateurs précédents les
départements vont mal très mal
aujourd'hui c'est un véritable appel au
secours qu'il lance les départements
sont le reflet de la triste réalité de
notre pays eux les départements à qui
l'on a confié la charge des solidarités
territorial et social sont impass de ne
plus pouvoir assumer le rôle naturel
d'amortisseur social de la crise parce
que paradoxalement l'État se refuse à
faire jouer la solidarité nationale si
seul quelques conseils généraux étai
touché par ce phénomène on pourrait
parler de mauvaise gestion mais
aujourd'hui ce sont l'essentiel des
départements qui connaissent des
difficultés et c'est donc bien un
problème structurel des finances
départementales que nous rencontrons et
qui mérite une réponse globale comme
l'ensemble de mes collègues président
conseil général je suis tout à fait
disposé à contribuer à l'effort de
redressement des comptes de la Nation en
adoptant notre budget en adaptant notre
budget à la raréfaction de l'argent
public mais pour cela il faudrait que
nous ayons les moyens et monsieur le
ministre nous ne les avons plus la
dévitalisation que vous souhaaitiez est
en bonne voie j'en veux pour preuve un
certain nombre d'indicateurs qui ne
cessent de se dégrader depuis le début
de la crise face aux dépenses de
solidarité qui ont explosé l'épargne
nette des départements n cessé de
baisser alors qu'elle était au niveau
nation de 4 milliards en 2013 elle tombe
à 1 milliard en 2015 et est estimée à
moins 8 milliards en 2020 pour mon
département j'enregistre une perte
d'éparet de 54 millions d'euros soit la
moitié de l'épargne figurant au budget
prévisionnel
2014 et je pense que ce constat n'est
pas un cas isolé au niveau national vous
comprendrez aisément que cela met en
péril notre capacit à financer des
opérations d'investissement et donc à
jouer un rôle actif de donneur d'ordre
pour l'économie locale ce sont ainsi des
milliers d'emplois notamment dans le
secteur du bâtiment et des travaux
publics qui sont menacés par l'absence
de marché soit lancé directement par les
départements soit par les collectivités
locales qui renoncent à leur projet
faute de subvention
départemental pour limiter ce phénomène
de nombreux départements ont fait le
choix de maintenir un niveau élevé
d'investissement en recourant à des
emprunts mais cette situation n'est pas
viable dans le temps car ces
collectivités sanste pour soutenir
l'économie locale le délai de
désentêement est passé de 4,6 années en
2013 à 8,8 années en 2015 sans compter
qu'il est estimé à 24 années en
2016 si je prends le barrain comme
illustration de mon propos nous sommes
passés de 5 3 années en 2013 à 7,6
années en 2014 uniquement pour pouvoir
maintenir un investissement autour de
200 millions d'euros par an aujourd'hui
je ne veux pas obérer l'avenir et
j'estime que les délais de 8 années pour
rembourser ne doit pas être dépassé ce
qui nous conduit à diviser
malheureusement par deux un
investissement pour 2015 imaginez les
conséquences c'est donc l'équilibre même
des budgets départementaux qui est
menacé nous sommes dans une situation
d'insolvabilité l tente face d'un côté à
des dépenses de solidarité qui explosent
et des charges incompressibles et d'un
autre côté à des recettes qui fondent
année après année en témoigne
l'autonomie fiscale des départements qui
n'a cessé de diminuer passant de 77 % en
2006 à moins de 44 % aujourd'hui et ce
dans mon département facteur aggravant
le taux de couverture par l'état du
reste à charge des dépenses sociales est
en diminution constante aujourd'hui il
est de 45 % dans le département du
barrain alors qu'en 2007 il était encore
de 65 %. cela représente une valeur de
162 millions d'euros à prendre sur mon
propre budget pour cette année et plus
de 900 millions d'euros depuis 2008 cela
est tout simplement inacceptable et
insupportable mais cette situation
pour être alarmante ne doit pas devenir
désespéré je veux rester positif si
l'État ne veut pas asphixer
financièrement les départements et leur
conserver un rôle éminent d'opérateur
économique local il peut je crois encore
le faire en a-t-il la volonté vous ne le
direz peut-être monsieur le ministre
pour cela il dispose de quelques leviers
qui pourrait permettre d'inverser la
tendance et redonner au département les
marges de manœuvre qui ont été les
siennes et qui lui ont permis de jouer
pleinement son rôle d'aménageur et de
garant des solidarités la première
proposition que je souhaite faire
aujourd'hui consiste à revoir le partage
de l'effort de redressement des comptes
publics il faut déduire les charges
supporté par le département au titre des
allocations individuelles de solidarité
de l'assiette des recettes
départementales prises en compte cela
permettrait de donner de l'air aux
finances du conseil général et lui
permettre de se désentêter tout en
initiant de nouveaux programmes
d'investissement la seconde de mes
propositions vise à revenir sur un
principe qui a été bafoué par tous les
gouvernements durant les dernières
années celui de la compensation des
dépenses de solidarité envers les plus
fragiles dans le barrain leur nombre est
passé de 15000 en 2008 à 35000 en 2015
l'absence de plus en plus pesante de
compensation des dépenses obligatoires
par l'État nous oblige ainsi à puiser de
plus en plus dans notre propre budget
pour financer une charge que nous
acquitons au titre de la solidarité
nationale aussi il ne me semble pas
déraisonnable de demander la
compensation intégrale des dépenses
liées à la seule prise en charge des
bénéficiaires du RSA afin de permettre
aux conseils généraux de jouer le rôle
aussi bien dans le cadre des solidarités
sociales que territorial ou alors l'état
décideur reprend à son compte la mise en
œuvre du RSA ma dernière proposition
permet d'aller un peu plus loin vers la
décentralisation des compétences dont
chacun s'accorde à dire qu'elle permett
un meilleur exercice des responsabilités
publiques tant dans la proximité que
dans l'efficacité ainsi l'État pourrait
utilement confier au département non
plus seulement la charge des allocations
individuelles de solidarité mais aussi
la définition des normes et des barê qui
enregissent
l'attribution la disparité entre les
territoires ne justifie pas toujours un
traitement centralisé uniforme de la
mise en œuvre et du calcul des
allocations individuelles de solidarité
l'adaptation à la situation locale
permettrait de garantir un service
public de meilleure qualité au juste
coût dans la mesure où les départements
sont les principaux financeurs il est
logique qu'il puissent aussi en être les
principaux
décideurs ou alors il faut tirer un
trait sur 30 ans de décentralisation et
redonner à l'état l'ensemble des
compétences sociales délégués avec la
certitude avérée qu'il n'est pas en
mesure de les exercer là est le
véritable problème des départements les
département sont pris en otage ce n'est
pas la hausse des impôts qui permettra
au départements d'assurer pleinement
leur mission de service public de
proximité mais bien la compétence de
déterminer eux-mêmes la gestion de leur
propre politique sociale
tels sont monsieur le Président mes
chers collègues les trois propositions
dont je tenais à vous faire part et qui
sont aujourd'hui je crois partagées par
bon nombre d'élus départementaux de
toute sensibilité monsieur le ministre
la situation est très grave n'attendez
pas qu'elle soit désespéré je vous
remercie la parole est à notre collègue
monsieur Vincent
Éblé
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président chers collègues ce débat
souhaité par la majorité sénatoriale est
utile pour rappeler dans quel contexte
évoluent les départements français
depuis de nombreuses années
singulièrement depuis les lois dites de
décentralisation de 200 4 porté par
notre éminent collègue de la Vienne
Jean-Pierre rafarin Premier ministre à
l'époque en 2004 mes chers collègues mon
voisin C Marnet et néanmoins ministre du
Budget Jean-François Copé rappelait
devant le Parlement que les transferts
de charges se feraient à l'euro l'euro
je crois pouvoir dire que nous
constatons unanimement sur les bands du
Sénat que cela s'est révélé pour le
moins
inexact il faut bien admettre
aujourd'hui si vous le dites monsieur le
Président il faut bien VI admettre
aujourd'hui que les lois de 2004 portent
en elle le germe de la lante asphyxie
des départements asphyxie que nous
n'avons cessé de dénoncer ces dernières
années alors même que sur les bandes de
droite on expliquait parfois doctement
que les difficultés que nous pointions
du doigt n'était que le fruit de notre
gestion hasardeuse je ne ferai pas ce
procès à nos collègues présidents de
département de droite qui désormais se
plaignent avec véhémence de ne plus
pouvoir boucler leur propre
pas de mauvais procès non plus mes chers
collègues de la majorité sénatoriale
pour avoir proposé ce débat aujourd'hui
à quelques jours du premier tour des
élections départementales tant nous
savons sur ces bancs que nos douleurs
départementales ne sont pas nées de la
victoire de la gauche en 2012 nous avons
tous fait des efforts pour financer des
dépenses de solidarité utiles mais
imposé j'y reviendrai vous en avez fait
à droite de l'hémicycle dans vos
départements nous en avons fait à gauche
dans les les nôtres cela s'est traduit
chacun le sait par la remise en cause de
certaines politiques innovantes et
volontaires par une réduction parfois
sensible des investissements par des
efforts de gestion incontestables en
terme de frais généraux et de dépenses
de personnel alors même que sabattait
sur nos collectivités un véritable effet
de ciseau effet amplifié par les
décisions prises lors du précédent
quinquena visant entre autres à
remplacer la taxe professionnelle une
taxe dynamique par une CVAE qui ne l'est
pas mais nous ne sommes pas là pour
refaire le match sur la pertinence de
cette réforme fiscale chacun sait
qu'elle a eu des effets bénéfiques sur
les plus grosses entreprises de notre
pays et négatif sur les PME notamment
artisanales et de service venons-en au
point majeur qui est à l'origine des
mots des départements qui viennent d'une
spécificité tout à fait inédite dans les
collectivités françaises et européennes
les départements sont les seules
collectivités librement administr
et élu au suffrage universel qui doivent
assumer financièrement une charge lourde
dont elle ne fixe ni le montant ni les
modalités d'entrer dans le dispositif je
veux bien entendu parler du RSA à partir
du moment où cet élément majeur de la
solidarité nationale n'est pas prise en
charge par l'État les finances des
départements sont mises à mal et ce
d'autant plus que nous sommes en période
de crise depuis les transferts de l'APA
de la PCH et surtout du RSA les
départements ont permis à l'état de
réaliser 55 milliards d'économie mes
chers collègues 55 milliards d'euros
ceci a bien failli porter le coût de
grâce à de nombreux départements sans
que la distinction droite gauche nopère
dès la fin 2012 l'ADF a obtenu du
gouvernement qu'il met en œuvre un
mécanisme permettant aux départements
les plus menacés de boucler leur budget
ce pacte de confiance s'est traduit en
2013 par le transfert des frais de
gestion de la taxe sur le foncier bâti
désormais perçu par les départements et
par la possibilité ouverte de porter à
4,5 % le taux des droits de mutation à
titre onéreux dont se sont saisis 91
départements sur 101 département de
gauche comme de droite à cela s'est
ajouté un fond de solidarité entre
départements visant à corriger les
inégalités de reste à charge des trois
allocations de solidarité alimenté par
un prélèvement sur le produit des DMTO
le fond de ensation perqué alimenté par
le produit de foncier bâtis transféré
est venu compléter ce dispositif et a
permis de ramener les écarts les écarts
à la moyenne pardon de reste à charge
des a à 22 %. ces dispositions sont
conjoncturelles mais elles constituent
un premier pas toutes les études le
montrent les départements sont ou seront
plongés dans des impasses budgétaires
dans les 3 à 5 années qui viennne la
réforme à venir doit donc être
structurelle je voudrais d'ailleurs
souligner le le travail fructueux du
Sénat qui en a défendu toutes les
spécificités toutes les aspérités et
même toutes les grâces dans le cadre du
débat sur les compétences cela a été
justifié et je pense que nous avons
collectivement été entendu par le
gouvernement mais je vous l'accorde sur
la question des finances les choses ne
sont pas encore réglées il va donc
falloir que l'État joue son rôle et je
propose que nous réfléchissions
collectivement à un mécanisme de
financement plus proche des réalités des
territoires concernés la péréquation
n'est pas la solution magique à tous nos
mots personnellement je n'y crois pas en
effet la péréquation a pour but de
corriger une situation financière
inégale entre les collectivités les plus
favorisées et celles qui le sont moins
or j'estime que cette inégalité doit
être traitée et corrigé à la source
c'est-à-dire au niveau des critères
fiscaux permettant aux collectivités de
générer des recettes financières à titre
d'exemple je suis élu d'un département
la cénémarne qui fournit nombre de
salariés à cemble de l'île-de-fance mais
mon département qui accueille peu
d'entreprises par rapport à Paris ou au
Haut- de scène n'a que peu de recettes
dans le cadre de la CVAE cela en raison
d'un mécanisme fiscal inadapté qui ne
tient compte que du siège social de
l'entreprise pour déterminer la
collectivité perceprice de l'impôt
cependant la charge financière c'est le
département où résident les salariés qui
la supportent et non pas celui où il
travaille bien que la péréquation tente
de réduire les inégalités financières
des départements elle est très loin de
les compenser or revoir les critères de
répartition de la CVAE en regardélément
plus pertinents tels que la
domiciliation des salariés par exemple
serait bien plus bien plus équitable et
efficace que d'utiliser un outil de
péréquation les départements ont
également besoin d'équipement et de
services pour accompagner les dynamiques
démographiques qui ne sont
malheureusement pas corrélé par les
dynamiques fiscales la cemarne reste le
département franilien et l'un des
départements français don dont la
population augmente le plus rapidement
et pourtant elle n'est qu'au
99e rang en ce qui concerne la DGF par
habitant clairement nous devons nous
réinterroger sur tous ces mécanismes
afin d'assurer un peu plus de justice
dans nos territoire l'espace de dialogue
ouvert avec le gouvernement sur la
question des compétences prouve que l'on
peut le poursuivre sur la question
financière nos département ne Quément
rien ils veut juste plus de justice eux
qui injectent 1 milliard d'euros dans
les politiques sportives pour les clubs
pour les équipements eux qui accordent
1illard 300 millions pour la culture qui
vit ou qui survit grâce au soutien des
collectivités territoriales faut-il le
rappeler eux qui sont venus en aide à
plus de 2 millions et demi de nos
concitoyens et sont à l'origine d'un
million d'emplois de service non
délocalisable avec 38 milliards d'euros
de budget eux qui ont accordé 4
milliards et demi d'euros à nos collèges
en fonctionnement et en investissement
eux qui sont les premiers financeurs
publics du monde associatif eux qui
donnent du travail au TPE et PME de leur
territoire et répondent présent au côté
des communes et des EPCI pour les
investissements propres à hauteur de 30
% en moyenne oui les départements
doivent avoir les moyens de mettre en
œuvre les politiques qui sont utiles à
leur territoire et au pays voilà
pourquoi mes chers collègues nous serons
toujours au côté des défenseurs des
collectivités départementales qui
entreront demain dans une are
nouvelle allez nous poursuivant la
parole est à notre collègue
Jean-Baptiste
Lemoine monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues à la
veille de l'élection des nouvelles
assemblées départementales le débat que
nous avons à l'initiative de la majorité
sénatoriale est de nature à éclairer
lesé lecteurs sur les défis que les
départements ont à relever dans un
contexte contraint le sujet est donc
d'actualité mais force est de constater
qu'il est d'actualité depuis longtemps
trop longtemps et que les majorités
successives depuis la décentralisation
de 1982 doivent toutes en prendre leur
part de responsabilité bref je pense que
si l'examen de conscience ne doit
exempter personne en revanche la volonté
de tirer les départements de ce mauvais
pas doit engager tout le monde
d'ailleurs relisant mon petit valallini
en 2010 lors de la réforme territoriale
je me suis dit qu'il y avit peut-être
des raisons d'espérer vous disiez à
l'époque Monsieur le Ministre cette
réforme est une occasion manquée elle
passe à côté du problème des ressources
des collectivités territoriales ce que
je regrette profondément alors je me
suis dit chouette ça va changer et puis
bon malheureusement on est encore au
point mort
hein alors commençons par le constat
partagé et l'origine des déséquilibres
auxquels les départements doivent faire
face si je prends un département que je
connais bien et que j'ai l'honneur de
représenter Lyonne la moitié du budget
départemental d'environ 400 millions
d'euros et est constitué de dépenses
d'action sociale ces 200 millions de
dépenses en prestation sociales dont les
règles sont fixées au niveau national
vous le savez se répartissent en qu/4
dont le poids est peu ou prou équivalent
la famille et l'enfance d'une part les
personnes âgées l'insertion et les
personnes handicapées là où le bablesse
c'est lorsqu'on constate un différentiel
croissant d'année en année entre les
recettes perçues au titre des
compétences sociales transférées et les
dépenses à engager si je prends le volet
insertion RSA la crise économique a
entraîné une hausse du seul RSA de 9 %
2000 3 de 10 % 2014 du coup le reste à
charge pour un département comme Lyonne
se monte à 17 millions d'euros
l'équivalent des montants fonctionnement
et investissement cumulés dédiés au
collège c'est vous dire ce que l'on
pourrait faire si une juste compensation
était mise en œuvre j'ajoute que lorsque
le Département souhaite amplifier le
travail de lutte contre la fraudte
sociale sur ce volet-là pour que chaque
euro dépensé soit utile et que nous
souhaitons proposer de financer des
postes supplémentaires de contrôleurs à
la CAF nous sommes renvoyés à nos
cherses études
alors que des annonces ont été faites ce
jour par le Premier ministre sur le RSA
et la PPE nous attendons monsieur le
ministre de l'exemplarité dans ce
dossier si les départements devaient
être impacté financièrement alors si je
prends un autre volet les personnes
âgées le reste à charge s'élève pour ce
département de Lyonne encore à 20
million d'euros donc au total ce sont
près de 40 millions d'euros de charges
supporté par le département à la place
de l'État ce qui représente tout de même
10 % du budget total l'équivalent de
notre plan numérique pour lequel nous
pourrions doubler la mise or on sait
qu'il y a des ATT très forte sur nos
territoirees de ce point de vue-là
reconnaissez que cela n'est pas une
paille et qu'il est déjà miraculeux que
les départements aent pu proposer des
budgets absorbant cette charge ce qui
s'est fait au prix de révision drastique
dans les autres politiques
départementales alors c'est vrai il faut
reconnaître que la décentralisation et
ces différentes étapes ne se sont pas
toujours accompagnées du transfert des
meilleures recettes il est évident que
leur dynamisme n'était pas forcément à
la hauteur je pense à à la TIPP et même
si les fractions de TIPP sont
régulièrement ajustées dans les les lois
de finances c'est pour couvrir le coût
historique constaté par l'État et non
pas pour tenir compte du coût réel
décaissé alors cert nous sommes toujours
ingénieux au Parlement au Sénat ou à
l'Assemblée nationale pour trouver des
rustines le FMDI est né ici euh les
fonds de péréquation divers et variés
ont été évoqués sont toujours là pour
apporter une petite poire pour la soif
mais ce n'est pas à la hauteur des
enjeux ni des écarts alors comme il faut
être équitable il faut dans le même élan
reconnaître que ce mode de compensation
est cel qui prévaut depuis la mise en
place de l'acte 1 de la décentralisation
sous le gouvernement de Pierre Morrois
il suffit d'ailleurs de comparer la la
dotation perçue par les département pour
les collèges et les sommes effectivement
dédiées à cette politique à périmètrre
constant pour voir que le malâ était
déjà en germe pour Lyonne la dotation
collège versée par l'État s'élève à 1,6
million d'euros 10 million de francs
comme en 1982 et les dépenses
équivalentes en 2013 s'élève à 7,3
million d'euros du simple au quadruple
alors certes la la compensation des
transferts et extension de compéten est
un principe à valeur constitutionnelle
depuis la réforme de 2003 mais si notre
ancien collègue Daniel Effel avait à
l'époque été plus écouté lors des débats
sur la loi organique relative à
l'autonomie financière des collectivités
peut-être n'en serions-nous pas là car
la rédaction de cette loi organique
reste à minima par rapport aux ambitions
qu'avait alors le Sénat et un certain
nombre d'associations représentant les
collectivités si bien que le Conseil
constitutionnel aujourd'hui peut veiller
au respect des dispositions de l'article
722 de la Constitution sans que cela
n'empêche l'accroissement du décalage
financier bien réel qui apparaît entre
les recettes affectées au transfert et
les charges croissantes que doivent
supporter les départements au point
d'ailleurs quelque part de dénaturer un
peu le principe de libre administration
des collectivités si on est lucide alors
naturellement la crise de 2008 n'a pas
arrangé les choses avec des recettes qui
se sont affaissées on pense au DMTO
naturellement un effet ciseau du coût
qui devient insupportable ce qui oblige
alors à réduire la voilure en matière
d'investissement or lorsqu'on sait que
les collectivités local représente 70 %
de la commande publique on voit tout
l'impact que ça peut avoir sur un
certain nombre de filières économiques
sur des emplois locaux qui se retrouve
sur la Cellette à cela s'ajoute le fait
que les départements n'ont quasiment
plus de de base fiscale sur lequelle ils
ont véritablement des leviers alors non
seulement dotations et recettes ne sont
pas au au rendez-vous mais en plus
l'état fait peser monsieur le ministre
sur les collectivités un effort trop
important dans le redressement des
comptes qu'en est-il du discours de
François Hollande à Dijon en 2012 qui
des des trémolot dans la voie assuraient
pas de baisse des dotations et nous
voilà réduit si je puis m'exprimer ainsi
à payer la chambre alors les seuls
départements vont devoir supporter 1,5
milliard d'euros de dotation au moins en
2015 une DGF qui a déjà après une DGF
qui a déjà diminué de 3,3 % en 2014 tout
cela n'est pas d'un très bon augure pour
le dynamisme de nos territoires alors
j'entends l'entienne reprise par
quelques beaux esprits appelant et je
cite la Vulgate là aussi à a freiner les
dépenses de fonctionnement des
collectivités territoriales comme le
précise effectivement un rapport de la
Cour des comptes dans son en octobre
2013 mais dans ce cas-là il faut
absolument cesser de transférer nombre
de missions que l'État n'est plus en
mesure d'assumer ou de financer les
départements les communes les interco
font voiture balai pour la République et
pour l'État on prend la fin de la
l'instruction des documents d'urbanisme
parler des DT moi j'ai regardé au niveau
de l'intercommunalité que je connais
bien du gâtinet en Bourgogne c'est un
ETP supplémentaire à à financer donc bah
voilà comment on fait euh alors on le
voit bien si ces tendances financières
et budgétaires se poursuivent monsieur
le ministre vous avez beau avoir
renoncer en parole à la suppression des
départements si rien n'est fait en acte
vous les condamnez effectivement alors
un petit mot de conclusion monsieur le
Président pour constater que l'aire des
bâtisseurs des présidents bâtisseurs av
vraemblement vécu dans nos conseils
généraux et que malheureusement nous
entrons un petit peu dans l'air des
présidents chef de bureau chargé de
gérer des guichets et ça ça c'est plus
ou moins une recentralisation avec des
départements croupion qui ne sont plus
que des opérateurs de la de la politique
sociale de l'État alors voilà il y a un
gros chantier à aborder remettre au goût
du jour véritablement ce principe de
subsidiarité et puis je le dis élus
ruraux de tout bord unissons-nous pour
faire entendre la voix du bon sens à nos
gouvernant merci à
vous merci
Jean-Baptiste la parole est à notre
collègue Monsieur Bernard
laland
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues les récents
débats sur la loi nôre ont montré
combien les sénateur étit attaché à une
division territoriale de proximité
autant le débat fut riche sur les les
frontières et sur les compétences autant
il a été très superficiel sur le
financement de cette réforme
structurelle et
ambitieuse de la commune en passant par
les EPCI les métropoles les conseils
départementaux les régions et la
multitude de syndicat et autres
organismes publics ou parapubl chacun a
voulu conserver son
précarré complex complexifiant ainsi les
futurs critères de
financement par ailleurs les
conséquences sur activité économique de
la crise financière de 2008 la
désindustrialisation de notre pays qui
n'a pas été anticipée dès les années
2000 l'amplification du recours à
l'emprunt comme variable d'ajustement
pour éviter de prendre les mesures
réalistes amène aujourd'hui le
gouvernement de la France à corriger les
ééments du passé et à adapter notre pays
à la nécessaire mutation des économies
occidental les mesures d'économie
proposées par le gouvernement sont pour
la majorité politique du Sénat
insuffisante au niveau national mais dès
lors qu'il s'agit de faire participer
les conseils départementaux au
redressement de notre pays en minorant
la DGF les mêmes élus expriment leur
désapprobation il demandent plus à
l'État qu'il trouve par ailleurs
impécugneux comme si les erreurs du
passé avaient été effacé par le
changement de majorité
nationale sans être provocateur mais
simplement curieux j'aimerais qu'on nous
indique comment on peut prévoir un plan
d'économie de 100 à 150 milliards sans
toucher aux recettes des conseils
départementaux représentant des
collectivités territoriales nous n'avons
pas d'autre choix que d'élaborer une
nouvelle architecture de la fiscalité
territoriale et en particulier de la DGF
parce que nous sommes légitimes pour le
faire parce qu'un très grand nombre
d'entre nous exerçons ou avons exercer
des fonctions de responsable de
collectivité parce que nous avons
l'expérience parce que tout simplement
c'est notre rôle de
législateur le constat de la Cour des
comptes sur la situation financière des
conseils départementaux met en évidence
la fragilité croissante des finances
départementales cette fragilité ne date
pas d'hier puisque pour la 5e année
consécutive le niveau d'investissement
des départements va
baisser ce sont ainsi depuis 2009 3,3
milliards d'euros qui n'ont pas profité
à l'aménagement territorial à la
solidarité avec les communes rurales les
dépenses de fonctionnement sont
principalement dédiés aux dépenses
sociales lesquelles ont augmenté de 10 %
depuis 2009 le RSA a atteint à lui tout
seul 30 % de ses dépenses l'aide aux
personnes âgées 24 % et l'aide aux
personnes handicapé 22
%. les départements sont donc confrontés
inexorablement à un effet de ciseau
entre la non évolution des recettes et
l'augmentation de leurs dépenses il le
maîtrise d'autant plus difficilement que
cette situation reflète celle de nos
concitoyens fragil fragilisé eux aussi
par la situation économique globale du
pays et par aussi
admettons-le un accroissement des
dépenses de fonctionnement courante lié
en partie à une augmentation de la masse
salariale qui
aurait selon les déclarations du
ministre éer progressé de 4 % en
2014 l'état des finances de nos conseils
départementaux et la conséquence de la
fragilisation de nos concitoyens nous ne
sommes pas élus que pour les jours
heureux mais aussi je dirais surtout
pour être la réponse à ceux qui ont
besoin d'équité de justice sociale
quelle est la plus belle réforme des 15
dernières années si ce n'est si ce n'est
celle de permettre aux plus âgés d'entre
nous de continuer à vivre chez eux la
pas la pas à un coup mais la pas est
justice la pas est tout à l'honneur des
réformateurs on ne peut pas être re
défenseur de la proximité citoyenne si
on ne répond pas aux attentes des plus
fragiles de nos
concitoyens notre gouvernement a sur
réagir face à l'urgence par la
conclusion du pacte de solidarité état
département l'accord de novembre 2014
pour le finance pour le financement
pérenne des allocations ais est
historique depuis les différentes vagues
de décentralisation c'est la première
fois que l'État accepte de déclencher
une aide de cette ampleur qui plus dans
un moment de tension sur les finances
publiques au total les mesures prises
ont permis de débloquer 1,6 milliards
pour les budgets départementaux 2014 le
transfert des frais de gestion du
foncier bâti a représenté une manne de
de 827 millions d'euros la possibilité
de relever le taux de droit de mutation
des droits de mutation à titre onéreux
jusqu'à 450 % ont vu 90 département
utiliser cette possibilité générant au
total 800 millions d'euros
supplémentaires auquel il convient
d'ajouter les dispositifs particuliers
au département d'Île-de-France sans ces
recettes à vérifier vérifiez-le sans ces
recettes complémentaires les marges de
manœuvre des départements auraient chité
de 22
%. la stabilisation de ces mesures
au-delà de 2016 comme l'a souhaité
l'Association des départements de France
va permettre de réduire l'effet de
ciseau et de réduire les inégalités
relatives au reste à charge en matière
d'AIS
toutefois le temps nécessaire au
redressement économique du pays et par
conséquent à l'emploi ne permet pas
d'espérer que ces dispositions seront
suffisantes il nous faut poursuivre dans
les deux voies possibles de la recherche
de l'économie de la recherche d'économie
et de la création de nouvelles
ressources pour les départements et
l'impérieuse nécessité de réformer en
profondeur la
DGF permettez-moi de conclure par des
éléments empruntés à l'excellente
communication de notre collègue François
Marc en commission des finances du 22
octobre dernier sur les perspectives
d'évolution de la dotation globale de
fonctionnement je cite il est presque
impossible de fournir une signification
scientifique et objective des critères
de répartition de la
DGF pour assurer une mesure objective il
faudrait pouvoir distinguer ce qui
relève des charges d'une collectivité et
ce qui relève de ses choix en matière de
service publ et donc de neutraliser les
choix politiques François Mar précise
par ailleurs que la répartition des
charges doit REPER reposer sur une juste
évaluation des charges et des richesses
des collectivités territoriales ce qui
constitue le point le plus polémique
dans la mesure où chaque collectivité
défend sa situation
spécifique paradoxalement un des
interlocuteurs auditionnés affirm qu'à
force d'additionner les critères
contradct ire on aboutissait à la même
répartition de la de la DGF que si on
l'avait réparti en fonction de la
population le projet de loi sur la
nouvelle organisation territoriale de la
République est une opportunité à saisir
pour reprendre pour répondre au
financement de nos conseils
départementaux je pense je crois nous
pensons nous croyons que c'est pour nous
et pour nous sénateurs une occasion
unique de travailler collectivement à
une redéfinition
à une adaptation de la fiscalité
territoriale aux compétences que la loi
donnera à nos départements je vous
remercie voilà pour ces débats dans
l'hémicycle sur le thème et bien de la
situation financière des conseils
départementaux des débats vous l'avez vu
assez vif les sénateurs sont assez
préoccupés par la baisse des dotations
et la hausse des dépense de certains
conseils départementaux ce qui se
conjugue avec un climat d'incertitude
lié à la réforme orial les sénateurs
n'ont pas hésité à égratiger cette
réforme qu'il jugent faite à la hâte
vous pouvez tjs voir et revoir toutes
les séances sur notre site
publicsenat.fr très bonne journée à vous
sur les chaînes
parlementaires